bonsoir maïtena guillaume depardieu
marica greg le millionnaire laurent
baffie maïtena la fille qui manque dans
le pape en ce moment insérez un sicilien
n'a pas trop hein ah non il n'a pas
d'autre c'est sûr mais qui a comme
concurrentes
il ya toutes les fictions dans
l'émission aussi on a pas mal et 1
personne alors maïtena depuis septembre
2001 vous animez les maternelles sur
france 5
8h45 ce qui nous a valu un 7 d'or le 7
d'or de la meilleure émission éducative
2003 voilà et le dimanche vous remettez
ça avec psychologie à 13h30 une émission
consacrée à la famille aux couples à la
spiritualité et à la sexualité vous dit
quoi sur la sexualité
on parle beaucoup de sexualité surtout
sur le plateau des maternelles je dois
quand même dire ah d'accord qu'il faut
faire des enfants faut coucher
oui c'est vrai que c'est au tour des
médecins il faut les y en a encore
beaucoup parler mais c'est bien
j'imagine visite quoi vous avons assisté
d'edf-- pressé écoute sur la sexualité
sur le poteau des maternelles on a fait
le plaisir masculin plaisir au féminin
on a fait ça c'est vraiment pour le
plaisir en famille au féminin c'est la
rédactrice en chef de l'émission qui
l'institué ça les femmes plus leur
plaisir en main
8h45 du matin les femmes prennent leur
plaisir en main alors maïtena faisait en
fait commencé votre carrière en suisse
pourtant vous êtes basque comme votre
nom l'indiqué maïtena biraben comment on
dit y retrouver en suisse à l'époque se
marier en suisse a pas trente neuf
raison d'y aller quoi on travaille dans
la finance
ça va on épouse en suisse voisine et +16
ça va pas durer les seuls union qui dure
sont celles qui ont lieu dans des
langues dans les émissions de
télé-réalité regarde le bachelor il est
toujours avec sa gonzesse
greg est toujours avec marie cas voilà
quoi
alors en suisse donc vous finissez par
faire une émission qui s'appelle ça
colle et ses piquants et c'est là que je
vous repère et je vous demande de venir
à paris parce que je pense que vous êtes
une énorme star de la chapelle dans un
premier temps d'honorer directement m
acheter un truc pour l'occasion ce que
j'étais tantale slip et j'avais
rencontré le garçon que je regardais au
fin fond de ma compagne quand j'étais
petit comme montbéliard se salit francis
gouraud instituteurs j'ai regardé
lunettes et j'avais revoilà et là je
vous je vous l'offre
dans un petit studio c'était en tout
bien tout honneur espionner vous
espionnez l'heure à laquelle je rentrais
vous fait des réflexions d euros voilà
vous êtes rentré tard hier ses draps
pour s'aider soi papa alors là c'était
un petit peu difficile on a essayé de
faire des émissions puisque c'est un peu
difficile on a essayé de faire des
émissions pour m6 ont essayé de faire
une émission pour france 2 qui
s'appelait vue sur la mer la fête voilà
jean pierre côté le directeur des
programmes étaient assez était assez
déçue je m'en excuse jean-pierre
pourtant si jean pierre cottet qui nous
engagera quelques années plus tard sur
l'a5
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes mûr pour
succès je pense ouais je pense que ça je
pense que toutes ces années comme ça
d'apprentissage de thierry vous le
pensiez déjà il ya sept ans le problème
c'est de savoir ce que vous êtes prête à
fermer et hénin pour arriver au top
à part ça chez media est ce que tu peux
faire d'autre
alors je suis ni seriez prête comme ça
pour arriver au top a passé une semaine
dans un conteneur de télé réalité avec
des gens comme gras gay américain si
thierry bombezin nord-ouest
l'accepterait oui est ce que vous êtes
prête pour arriver au top à raconter vos
échecs amoureux chez mireille dumas nom
dans le mannequinat il faut en mettre un
peu un peu de bonne volonté je n'ai pas
tant que ça et puis
ils sont plaints d'avoir avec pirelli
sont d'une banalité tellement exigeante
que je pense pas que ça fascine les
foules
vous n'êtes pas prête à raconter vos
échecs amoureux chez mireille dumas est
ce que vous êtes prêtes à poser dans
paris match en tant que fiancée de
bernard montiel
ah oui ça c'est bien voilà j'ai senti de
la carrière au tir et mais c'est
incroyable dernière t'embrasse est ce
que pour arriver au top vous n'êtes pas
ta interviewé tu redescends et comment
aïe
et comment